hi there steve kaufman here
i'm back from montreal
i uh attended a conference there
called an international conference on
multilingualism linguistic challenges
and neurocognitive mechanisms
and
i attended the conference
in the hope that it would provide me
with some insights on language learning
which i could use for my own language
learning which we could introduce
perhaps at link
and
i will post by the way
a link to the conference
here
because they are going to put up
i gather
full
videos of all of the presentations so uh
you can all
participate unless that's somehow
limited to people who were signed up i
don't know but
um i will post a link
um
my conclusions um i didn't learn
much really that is relevant to language
learning
i had a wonderful time i enjoyed being
in montreal
montreal is really amazingly bilingual
when you you see people in the streets
switching back and forth from english to
french if you're in a restaurant or
a bar you have no idea if the person
serving you is english anglophone or
francophone because they seem to speak
both languages so freely
so it's quite a unique experience
and i like downtown montreal around
mcgill university and
and uh you know the different streets
there
um
the uh concert the conference was
sponsored by the school of communication
sciences and disorders
disorders of mcgill university
the people
the linguistics and and brain i guess
the neuro
scientists and people they were
extremely nice and friendly and
enthusiastic
and so it was a wonderful two days
the um
the uh and it was a whole new field for
me i spent the first day not
understanding a lot of it because they
were talking about
n400 and p600 you know what n400 is
it's a reaction in your brain after 400
milliseconds when you discover something
that uh
maybe shouldn't be there or whatever and
then and i'm not sure the difference
between an n400 and a p600 but these are
things that
these people measure
uh and a lot of the uh i should have
that there were like presentations every
half hour there are a lot of
presentations in addition to which they
had these poster sessions where people
would uh put up posters describing the
type of research they've been doing
and and you could interact with them and
ask them questions and so forth so
there's a massive amount of information
most of it having to do with very
specific and very sort of detailed
studies of some aspect of
of near
neurocognitive mechanisms and so they
measure
how the brain
reacts to
certain stimulus which could be
something that's correct or incorrect in
speech and so forth
so it went into a lot of this kind of
detail
i mean i read here morphological
processing in late bilinguals the role
of language experience in the neural
cognition of late learned language
bilingual l3a versus monolingual l2a
cross-linguistic syntactic priming in
german english bilinguals the role of
global and surface syntactic structure
and and it just goes on and on like this
and
you know i guess i'm still trying to
process
this whole new world
for me
but uh i was not the only one who
was there who was not from this specific
background
and who felt it wasn't very relevant to
language learning
so it's a different world
i have to bear in mind that the school
of communication sciences and disorders
a large part of their purpose is to
train
speech pathologists and people like that
who help those people who have you know
difficulties auditory difficulties
speech difficulties and so forth and so
it's almost as if
language learners were treated as some
kind of a
you know pathological case and so they
measured how the brain reacts and so
forth and so on
um
it was interesting in talking to people
because it was very easy to talk to
people everybody was happy to talk to
you about what they were doing about or
about anything in general
and
the attitude about language learning or
the relevance of this to language
learning
i would say that it varied from one
person who felt that if
language learners were taught
linguistics that they would learn
languages faster this was very much a
minority view a majority of people
actually believed that and i think it
also came through in the presentations
that ultimately language acquisition
depends on exposure
which is not earth shouting earth
shattering really
and
and many people confirmed that there was
this dichotomy between the
kind of research that is done
and then the needs of the language
acquisition
community although
theoretically
you know these people many of them were
involved in both areas so for me it was
very exciting to be introduced to a new
sort of discipline
and i'm truly still sorting out what the
relevance of this is
to uh language learning and i'll
probably watch the videos again because
first time through there's a lot that i
didn't quite understand
uh so that was the um
one thing by the way as i was i took a
taxi in montreal and the taxi driver was
italian which i could tell by his accent
in french so then we switched to italian
he spoke french very fluently but he
spoke with a very heavy italian accent
he'd been living in montreal for 35
years i think he was about maybe in his
mid 50s
so um
what does that say
it just says that
you can be exposed to the language and
and develop a high degree of fluency
and yet
not change your accent at all
and yet you can have someone who within
a year or two
uh you have like lucca from rome
who uh
you know speaks french like a native is
that talent is that
well is that
you know depends on i guess your goals
your motivation
i mean i uh i came away i guess
more confirmed than ever in in the
belief that uh
language learning is all about what you
want to do it's motivation
motivation spending the time and
and as i say this this ability to notice
which can be helped by
studying grammar or interacting with a
teacher but but that's a small part and
that the big part is the motivation and
the amount of time exposure to the
language uh
and so details of what you do and so
forth don't matter
and it doesn't matter how old you are
this is something that came through in
the conference the sort of increasing
awareness of the importance of
of this
neuroplastic plasticity that we have
a number of people also confirmed that
these ideas of of a universal grammar
are
are basically fading out of favor
linguistics becomes more of a science of
observation experimentation and looking
at how the brain actually reacts to
different stimuli different uh exposure
to different forms of the language or
different languages
rather than a linguistics that was based
on some logical extrapolation a
lachansky's universal grammar
although the defenders of the universal
grammar continue to support it and claim
that it's constantly
evolving
however
the fundamental tenet of universal
grammar is that there is insufficient
stimulus you know
for a child to simply start speaking
after two or three years
which suggests
at least to chomsky that therefore there
must be some inherent
ability to to
identify or to create language based on
certain inherent grammatical rules
whereas i think
increasingly with this experimentation
and so forth at least a number of people
that i spoke to agreed with me that it's
basically the brain responding to
stimulus the way it responds to other
stimulus and forming rules and patterns
to deal with it in the brain
uh
but that's about as far as i'm gonna
venture because i'm not
really qualified to say much more so
a pleasant experience i'm not sure what
it does for language learning or for my
understanding of language learning
but i enjoy myself so thank you for
listening bye for now